good morning John and Hank it's Friday
my name is Rosie Anna I'm John's
producing partner John and Hank secret
sister a youtuber over at youtube.com
slash where's Janna and an avid user of
the Internet that being said today's
video is about logging up not too long
ago I hit my limit of the social
Internet I scrambled my passwords I
deleted apps from my phone I backed
quickly away and promptly read more
books in a week than I'd read in the
previous two months I found that I was
less anxious less angry and I
communicated far better with friends
about how I was actually doing I'm not
here to say though that the Internet is
that for one I love thousands of
kilometres away from most of my friends
so I love seeing updates from Nando's or
from the central line for tool I don't
think the Internet is intrinsically
anything it's a tool and system we use
and I read a piece in off-screen
magazine recently that kind of summed
this up for me we think the Internet is
inherently a certain way but it isn't
it's constantly changing and we are the
ones who are changing it we can change
it for the better rather than having to
change ourselves to adapt the parts of
it that are toxic for us the internet
seems like it's made up of code and
clouds but really it's made up of people
like so much it comes back to community
prior to my mini internet break part of
my reluctance to step back is that I've
defined myself through the internet I've
defended the Internet to other people
I've defended the joy of meeting
strangers and the special thrill of
making something with people you will
never meet whether that's something
deeply useful deeply silly or something
that falls somewhere between the two
that may bring a smile but won't
necessarily feed the world a friend of
mine suggested to me that maybe the
Mercurius of Internet that led to me
taking a break and is infused through
all of these discussions of online
discourse is that it wasn't really
designed to hold so many people maybe
when I used to log onto AOL always after
6 p.m. and only if my sisters weren't on
the phone there were fewer people online
and that's what made it fun we were
working out together and building it
together rather than entering an
internet which felt as ready-made as
IKEA furniture with experts and pros and
rights and wrongs and yes the occasional
missing bolts I struggled to believe
that though I think we're still building
the Internet there are still voices we
aren't hearing there's still more work
to do it reminds me of one of my
favorite scenes from The West Wing when
a character called Jeff asked Josh to
take out a dollar bill turn it over and
look at the incomplete pyramid he says
the seal is meant to be unfinished
because this country is meant to be
unfinished we're meant to keep doing
better
yes it's idealistic but I genuinely
believe that the internet is not an ayah
bunker buried deep deep deep deep
underground its infrastructure and as
humans change and we
more about what helps us and helps other
people the internet will change and we
will change it we will have more and
better ideas about what to do next not
what to do last having said all of that
with such confidence I think we are at a
time of Internet when a lot of people
claim to know the right answer and the
idea that the mass of humanity can be
broken down into bullet point lists or
alphas and betas is to me contradictory
to everything that humans have
demonstrated over time maybe we start by
not knowing and what was helpful to me
in my time stepping back from the
internet was realizing how bloody long
it had been since I had clicked logout
or log off since I have made an
intentional and active decision about my
online behavior rather than a passive
one it clicked oh when I open my
computer I'm often on automatic my
Twitter feed my inbox my calendar I'm
kind of in a nothing state and in that
nothing state I am plasticine and Who am
I handing that plasticine to just to get
fully quick tastic here and Eleni
letters a to smith recently broke the
fields have to possess a certain amount
of vertical depth
it's like mowing a stone down into the
well of yourself and the further it goes
the deeper it results a lot of the
social platforms provoke feelings in me
I simply don't enjoy for a moment I'm
flattered
falsely puffed up briefly amused
painfully hurt or infuriated Johnny
recommended to me the brilliant podcast
invisibie Leah and on that there was an
episode about how in Rwanda legislation
had been passed to require equal
representation in government but that
episode was also about how that
legislation didn't necessarily affect or
improve gender inequality around the
country essentially and I'll put the
full episode in the description bar
below because it's great that shortcut
didn't quite work and it made me wonder
whether Twitter was a shortcut that
didn't quite work whether we needed to
do more long hard work to get to some of
the benefits and include some of the
benefits that websites like Twitter
provide hearing for more voices
community organizing because otherwise
we maybe have a bit of a tendency to
feel stuck or feel like those are the
ultimate solutions the long hard work
maybe doesn't let us pretend to rest
easy and admire the pyramid and see it
as complete the truth is I don't know
and I'm curious to hear your thoughts
John I'll see you on Tuesday